der Militärexperte und
Politikwissenschaftler der
bundesuniversität in München Carlo
Masala ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet einen
schönen guten Morgen
schönen guten Morgen Frau vom Weidenfeld
wie ist denn ihre Einschätzung in
welcher Lage befindet sich gerade die
ukrainische Armee
die ukrainische Armee befindet sich
meines Erachtens in einer ziemlich
entscheidenden Lage weil sie dabei ist
eine Gegenoffensive im Süden
vorzubereiten oder sagen wir es mal
präziser mehrere kleinere
gegenoffensiven im Süden die darüber
entscheiden werden ob Sie in der Lage
sein werden in Russen dort Territorium
zu entreißen gleichzeitig sehen wir dass
die Russen ihre Truppen im Donbass
ausdünnen um sie im Süden zu verstärken
was wiederum auch Möglichkeiten eröffnen
könnte für die ukrainische Armee im
Donbass selber
Geländegewinne gut zu machen sollte eine
solche Situation eintreten dann kann
sich das Bild in diesem Krieg der
Gestalt ändern das Russland zum ersten
Mal damit konfrontiert ist dass ihnen an
einer Reihe an einer großen Reihe an
dieser Front Territorien entrissen
werden und dann könnte sich
möglicherweise das russische Kosten
Nutzen Kalkül ob es eine Fortführung des
Krieges wirklich im russischen Interesse
weiterhin ist als ich anfangen zu
verändern wir hören aktuell das
Washington ausgeht von 80.000 gefallenen
oder Verwundeten russischen Soldaten für
wie realistisch halten Sie diese Zahl
das ist glaube ich eine ziemlich
realistische Zahl wenn man sich die
verschiedenen Berichte über gefallene
russische Soldaten anschaut dann kommt
diese Zahlen möglicherweise der Realität
ziemlich nah und zeigt aber auch
deutlich wenn Sie sich erinnern dass im
Februar
also vor dem
24.290.000 russische Soldaten
schätzungsweise an den an der Grenze zu
der Ukraine standen wie enorm die
russischen Verluste dort sind zählen sie
die Verluste von Material und Geräten
noch dazu muss man ganz einfach sagen
dass Russland für diesen Krieg dass die
russische Armee für diesen Krieg ein
unglaublich hohen blutsoll zahlt jetzt
hat ein Bericht von Amnesty
International gestern für Aufregung
gesorgt darin wird da Ukraine
vorgeworfen Zivilisten zu gefährden in
dem eben das militär-
naja es ist ein bisschen problematisch
und nach all dem was man über diesen
Bericht weiß hatte Amnesty keine Leute
vor Ort hat sich darauf verlassen auf
Leute die dort leben die ihre Berichte
aber sozusagen nur mit russischer
Zustimmung rausbringen konnten aus dem
Don was zum Beispiel also da stehen sind
schon große Zweifel an den Berichten
aber generell muss man ja folgendes
sagen die Russen erobern Stadt für Stadt
in Johannes und im Donalds wie soll man
Städte verteidigen wenn man nicht
sozusagen Truppen in Städte hat wie soll
man es schaffen die russische Armee aus
den Städten heraus in ich sag jetzt mal
offenes Gebiet zu bekommen um sie um
dort gegen sie zu kämpfen also was
dieser MSC Bericht den ich sozusagen
jetzt nicht anzweifeln will der Gestalt
das natürlich irgendwie die
Stationierung von Militär in der Nähe
von Zivilisten Zivilisten gefährdet das
ist richtig und das gegen humanitäres
Völkerrecht verstößt
ignoriert aber die Frage wie verteidige
ich den Städte wenn der Angreifer in
Städten sozusagen operiert dann kann ich
sie nur verteidigen indem ich meine
eigenen Streitkräfte auch in Städten
habe also von daher ist diese
Gleichsetzung von die Ukraine Verletzung
monetäres Völkerrecht und die Russen
machen Kriegsverbrechen die ist schon
hoch problematisch dann sprechen wir
noch über eine Strategie wenn sie denn
eine sehen mittlerweile auf westlicher
Seite die USA haben jetzt noch mal
Militärhilfen im Wert von einer
Milliarde US-Dollar angekündigt ja wie
bewerten sie das und wie positioniert
sich auch Deutschland die deutsche
Bundesregierung bzw Europa
also ich bewerte das so dass zunächst
einmal das möglicherweise eine der
letzten großen Hilfslieferungen der
Vereinigten Staaten sein wird weil die
Vereinigten Staaten auf die mit terms
zulaufen und die Unterstützung der
Ukraine dann doch zumindest in der
Bevölkerung nicht unumstritten ist
gleichzeitig muss man aber sagen dass so
groß dieses Hilfspaket ist die USA
bleiben in der Linie dessen was sie
bisher geliefert haben nämlich alles
Gerät wie Haubitzen Artillerie
Ortungssysteme Munition die ist in
Ukrainern ermöglichen die Russen auf
Distanz zu halten die Russen den den
Russen Schäden hinter der eigenen
russischen Front zuzufügen aber es wird
weiterhin nichts geliefert was den
Ukrainern es möglich machen würde Gebiet
zurückzuerobern also da rede ich über
sozusagen westliche Kampfpanzer oder
Kampfflugzeuge ich gehe davon aus dass
alle Regierungen der NATO und der EU
weiter in dieser Tradition bleiben
werden das zu liefern was auch die USA
geliefert haben von daher glaube ich
auch dass die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
hier weiter das liefern wird was sie
bisher geliefert hat aber die Frage ist
reicht das aus um die Ukraine bei ihrer
Gegenoffensive massiv zu unterstützen
sehen Sie denn auch also vielleicht noch
mal ganz kurz zum Schluss die Frage ist
ja letztlich welchen Preis ist man
bereit zu zahlen hat die Energiefrage
die Debatte um das militärische
Engagement diesen Krieg schon überlagert
sie fängt an die Debatte um militärisch
Engagement zu überlagern vor allen
Dingen in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und es ist zu befürchten dass im Herbst
ich glaube darauf spekuliert Putin auch
im Herbst wenn in der Ukraine die Kämpfe
auch schwerer werden weil der Boden
sozusagen matschig ist das Putin darauf
spekuliert dass dann durch die
explodierenden Gaspreise durch die
Nachzahlungen die öffentliche Stimmung
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zum
Beispiel kippt und der Druck auf die
Regierung größer wird jetzt endlich die
Ukraine zu irgendetwas zu drängen was
einem ein Kompromiss mit den Russen ist
ich glaube das ist Teil der russischen
Kriegsführung Strategie in dem in der
größeren Perspektive dass man darauf
spekuliert
Politikwissenschaftler und
Militärexperte Carlo Masala war das
vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und das
Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen